you know but it's true man everybody's
like [__] oh my god what are we gonna do
what the [__] are you gonna do i mean
you people honestly you're all young
you don't give a [__] about caitlyn i
have time invested in caitlyn okay
i'm an old man i hate the wheaties
[__]
after i saw him i wanna [__] do that
[__] dude
i ain't the wheaties [__]
so [__] you guys you have no investment
in them you know from some e-show and
[__]
school gonna look at him like a great
man like think about that [__]
you [__] young kids are gonna go to
school bruce jenner switched he switched
governments
he's a great [__] man that's what we
[__] need to add to these watered
down [__] kids as it is
these kids are getting weaker and
[__] weaker now we want to let me
tell you something about let me tell you
a story right
i'm a [__] uncle i got nephews i
can't i don't even want them
i don't even want them one plays the
flute i don't want them
what are you jack no get the [__] out of
here
hold on [__] [__] nephews on the
[__] nephews that rock the house
[__]
my one nerf you turn 14 thursdays
wednesdays when i got i caught anything
like get off the phone like what are you
doing i'm playing the game get the [__]
out of here
playing a game at 14 i was out there
[__] hanging out by the swamps taking
those punks
those little punks and lighting them on
fire they keep the mosquitoes away and
then you
you knock on people's door and you sell
them for a [__] dollar i was out
there hustling you put a quarter in the
newspaper you take all of them out you
sell them on the corner
but you don't sit there and play [__]
games i was a pimp when i was eight
years old
not a pimp pimping out [__] let me
tell you what i was doing at eight years
old
i had this guy in my neighborhood right
i used to live on 88th street in a nice
neighborhood with my mom
but on the weekends i go to my
godmother's house 148 and the kids
[__] it up up there
that's why i seen my first dead body i
mean that's a great [__] neighbor
when some kid shows you a dead body
under a piece of wood that's your best
friend for life when you're a kid
holy [__] how'd you know about that i
still remember the stink they didn't
give a [__] they're like oh
[__] it we come down here every day and
play stickball with them and [__] like
that
these kids were [__] tough these 148
street kids
but when i was up there i just come from
cuba and i was a nerdy kid i didn't know
the language i was very insecure so i
used to build models you know like
little [__] little models
spider-man the hulk and all that stupid
[__]
and i used to get the glue from this
[__] glue shot and i go in there with
a little hasidic jew that ran the place
you tell me [__] that guy don't sell him
no [__] glue there was this guy
that's
hung out outside you know when you're a
kid and you're hanging outside the
liquor store and some guy comes and you
give him money to get your beer
when we were kids there was an old guy
that used to give us money to get him
glue
[__] tremendous i'm like eight i get
him like a tuba glue a quarter and the
[__] jew guy would say don't give him
no [__] glue he's no good
and uh he was a nice guy he used to just
build models you know
he's a little creepy but who am i the
judge you know
and then one day i was helping my
godmother with the garbage can and i
actually saw him
behind the garbage can hoofing on a bag
like like a bag of glue whatever the
[__] they put it they put in the bag and
they hoof it
and i pulled the garbage can he got up
but this the bag stuck to his hand
so i called him sticky charlie and the
name stuck right
sticky charlie sticky charlie [__] you
he would get pissed off
so he was a little bit of a [__] he
went to vietnam right
and he got hit in the head with a
missile or some [__] like that
and he was getting like a monthly check
on the first and he'd just buy a box of
[__] glue like he spent
the whole three hundred dollars on glue
and he had these two glue hoes
and they take him to his mother's
basement and they dance around snoring
glue and [__]
for about 18 days and they run out of
glue and they need to be out in the
street you know
trying to hustle glue from us [__]
kinfolk you know so so i put it together
after like two months i'm like [__] this
[__] i'm gonna start pimping this [__]
out so
i got my mother to give me like 16 bucks
and i bought the whole case of glue
and i put like a 40 cents tack on it and
one day he's like hey his 25 cents get
me a tube of glue i'm like
sticky charlie
there's a new sheriff in town [__]
it's 65 cents what the [__] are you
talking about 65 cents a [__] okay
he's like [__] you [__] boy i'll go up
to the stands and get glue up down like
too late
me and my little cohorts drove a picture
of you snorting gloom we passed it out
to all the hobby and hardware stores
so he would have to go all the way to
the bronx to her [__] paint we had
him snorting paint
he would get pimples on his necks little
white heads and shake around and get
headaches but we didn't give a [__]
he say sell me the glue i'm getting
headaches i don't give a [__]
kids don't do that no more are they they
don't have that
they don't have that type of mentality
like to [__] hustle these guys
and sticky charlie lived until about 10
years ago i bumped into a friend of mine
on myspace when myspace was popular
and i he asked me remember sticky
charlie he just died oh [__]
and he snorted glue all the way to the
end
and he didn't die from glue he died from
something else so glue don't kill if
you're thinking of [__]
getting off oxycontins and looking for a
substitute
[Laughter]
glue is making a comeback [__]
you